Everything worth doing in life,
learn to ride a bike,
learning to walk.
When I was a kid,
learning to walk,
I fell and cracked my skull,
but I needed to learn to walk,
taking a test,
getting married,
getting a driver's license.
All of those things,
they give you an improved capability or
an improved richness in life,
but they all come with a degree of risk
that is exaggerated.
If the thing that you want to do is fly
a rocket ship,
rocket ships are dangerous there.
It's a controlled explosion.
If you drew a cartoon of a rocket,
what it would be?
Would it be a bomb with six seats on the
top?
I mean,
rocket ships are crazy dangerous on the
first flight of the space shuttle.
When Bob Crippen and John Young,
we're sitting there back in 1981 and
they blast it off out of Florida.
Now that we go back and we look at what
the actual history of the space shuttle
was,
their odds of dying that day in the
first eight and a half minutes were one
in nine.
Terrible odds.
One in nine.
I mean,
look around you and had 10 people and
realize that just to try that one and
nine times they would have died.
They got away with it and we learned a
lot from it,
but even when I flew on my first shuttle
flight on the 74th shuttle flight,
we'd learned enough things.
We'd improved it,
but the odds of dying that day for my
crew were still one in 38,
which is no insurance company would be
happy with.
It's hard to get life insurance as an
astronaut actually.
But.
But the question you really need to ask
that is,
do I want to learn to walk?
Do I want to ride this bike?
Do I want to get married?
Do I want to learn to drive a car?
What risks are worth taking in my life?
Because even if you decide,
okay,
I'm going to take no risk,
I'm going to stay at home and hide under
my pillow.
There's still risk with that and you're
still gonna die eventually anyway.
So it's kind of a measure of what was
worth doing in your life and therefore
what was worth taking a risk for.
Once you've got that behind you and
said,
okay,
I'm going to be an astronaut,
I'm going to fly a rocket ship.
That's a risk I'm going to take now.
It changes your whole job.
Your job is not to be afraid.
Your job is not to be,
uh,
an incompetent nervous passenger.
Your job now is to defeat the risk.
Like when you learn to ride a bike,
if you just stay as a passenger in the
bike,
you're never gonna know what to do with
the handlebars and you're never going to
master riding a bike.
And once you can ride a bike,
you know you've got a freedom you never
had before and rocket ships or just the
same.
You have to decide what risks are worth
taking and then start changing who you
are,
learning how to turn the handlebars so
that you could make this thing do
something that otherwise might hurt you
or kill you.
And then once you've got that done,
it can take you to places and give you a
richness in your life that you never
would have had access any other way.
And,
and in my case,
when you make it through that launch,
when you've guided that rocket up
through the atmosphere and the engine
shut off,
suddenly you're in the rarest of human
experiences.
You're weightless and the world is
pouring by at five miles a second,
and you can see across an entire
continent and,
and your,
your piering into something that is
brand new for humanity.
So,
uh,
I think it's worth asking yourself what
risks are worth taking.
And once you've decided to take them,
then change who you are so that you can,
when you can defeat,
you can master that thing and open a
door for yourself that otherwise was
just shut.